I focused with all the famous people
around the war I came finally to focus
on some individuals not so well-known
that maybe not known at all
this is dr. Edward Barsky who was a
surgeon in New York of a distinguished
family of surgeons but himself of
Communists Believe It or Not Barsky and
also ill with colitis Barsky volunteered
for the war after raising a great deal
of money for ambulances and and then
thinking who's going to go over there
put him together their supplies for a
complete mobile hospital unit and then
it became obvious that he was the one
who needed to lead this operation so he
went over he participated in every way
in the war he did a the kind of heroic
surgery that people do in wartime where
the surgeon operates for 30 hours
non-stop and then collapses for a few
hours and then goes back to work he also
came back to the United States from time
to time to raise more money what was
amazing to me is I found a cache of
documents that had never seen the light
of day really at New York University's
Tama man Library which has a large
labor-related collection including a
complete book manuscript of barsky's a
memoir 400 pages long that he wrote with
the help of a woman journalist that was
so brown with age that we couldn't even
scan it the type typewriter type was was
barely darker than than the paper by
then this should have been published
years ago but one of the tragedies of
the war is that people came back from
the war with whatever stories they had
to tell and within four months the
Second World War began in Europe and it
simply swamped out everything and after
the war with the rise of McCarthy asked
anti-communism in the United
Barsky was harassed by the house on
American Activities Committee found in
contempt of Congress because he wouldn't
give up the names of his comrades thrown
in federal prison for six months and had
his license lifted medical license for
six months and then got out and went
right back to doing what he did so well
he participated in the civil rights
movement in the south he participated in
the in the protests against the war in
Vietnam he continued throughout his life
to be the idealistic and dedicated man
he was but that is a book there really
still needs to be published and it was
full of wonderful stories including the
phrase that makes the title of the book
Barsky at one point in this memoir says
war is hell with all of the metaphysical
complexities of that word but it's also
damn good company so hell and good
company
[Music]